[Music]
come on Doc all right sit it's an
airship nothing bad ever has ever
happened on an airship Big Finish Doctor
Who time and this time I took a listen
to the very first adventure of Paul
McGann back is the Eighth Doctor after
his inauspicious debut in the TV movie
not his fault he was actually really
good even in that not very good thing
but this was his finally his return as a
performer you know the Eighth Doctor had
been used in other ancillary media
novels comics what-have-you but this was
the the return of Paul McGann in the
part I was excited to listen to this and
it was really great to have him back in
this so he let before I get too much
into it
let's talk Seth and I now go
spoiler-free for as long as I can on
this there's really only one or two
spoilers things I kind of want to touch
on at the tail end so but I can hold off
on that so the setup on this is the
doctor initially traveling alone and
dealing at first with sort of saving
this ship there's a bit of time he why
meanness and he finds himself on the
r101 now I don't know how well-known
this particular piece of history is
within the UK I would assume it's
probably better known that it is in the
US but speaking as an American I didn't
know what the auro 101 was I am going to
say what it is I don't consider this to
be a spoiler because actually knowing
the what the historical event of this
doesn't make this a worst list I
actually would think it makes it better
all explain why in a second so the R 101
was an airship akin to the Hindenburg
now it didn't end as quite as
spectacularly as the Hindenburg did but
it also didn't end a heck of a lot
better than a Hindenburg did so that's
our setup and what I said I don't think
it's much of a spoiler
point that out because this being a
doomed voyage factors into this cuz the
doctor shows up and realizes that right
off the bat and informs his decisions
and some of the things going on so
setting out on this is like setting
something on the Titanic like you know
what's coming and you're kind of
supposed to so but I still like the
selection of the r101 as opposed to say
the Hindenburg which I again speaking as
an American and I think this is
generally true is the much more
universally known you know Zeppelin
airship disaster if you think Zeppelin
you wow you even think lead or you think
Hindenburg the r101 was not something I
was particularly familiar with so I
rather like that it was a setup that was
not necessarily the most cutting-edge
thing in the world in terms of if you're
gonna set it in a past disaster scenario
you know doctor who's done it a few
times with well Titanic in space but
also with Pompeii and it's not uncommon
with time travel you know stories in
general but to pick something that is a
disaster and and is in the history books
but is not one of the big iconic ones
that everyone knows I think is actually
kind of a neat bouncing trick because it
doesn't feel as tired as something like
the Titanic kind of would even though
I'll probably continue to make
comparisons of the Titanic anyway just
cuz it's a frame of reference that I
know I'd sue me so we've got the doctor
we had the introduction of Charlie who I
guess actually becomes his companion for
a while following this and she is a
pretty good character she gets a decent
introduction when we first meet her
she's actually pretending to be male
she's passing herself off as a cabin boy
that doesn't last very long
but we don't actually get a ton about
her we get the basics but the basics
that she has are the basics you want for
our companions of the doctor which is a
sense of adventure and the ability to
just kind of roll with weirdness when it
happens she's got both of those so um
and and on top of that pretty decent
chemistry with McGann so as far as I'm
concerned even though her debut and this
didn't make her go oh she's
amazing character it didn't make me go
that's a solid debut and you can
definitely build some really good stuff
off of that so I don't know what the
general opinion on her is whether she's
highly regarded or not but I would say
that this this is a strong debuting
union there are definitely some very
good places that that this can be taken
this solid foundation for on ongoing
companion so nicely done there the rest
of the supporting cast is pretty good as
well but why I want to particularly
highlight though is a character of Lord
Tamworth who basically is is in charge
of the r101 he's the one you know giving
the orders making the decisions is he
gets the final call over what's going on
and his personality is again to make the
comparison you know sort of that that
overconfident over proper you know
blustering sort of Englishmen that you
know captain of the Titanic feel to him
that sort of oh we must [ __ ] in for
glory well here we go don't worry about
that and oh don't bother me with details
like we've overloaded the ship let's -
for the Keating ha and so it's got that
vibe to it but at the same time he's
actually afforded a lot more depth and a
lot more nuance than you would do it
then you would usually get for a
character like that so when he finds
himself in situations that are beyond
the scope of his experience and he's
dealing with things that he just doesn't
have a frame of reference for at all
instead of just sort of going
this is most irregular which is kind of
what you'd expect out of a character who
seems to be built like this he instead
adjust he he listens he pays attention
he alters his way of doing things
there's more to him than just the
bluster and that was kind of nice and
refreshing I rather enjoyed it and that
whole general vibe that sort of stiff
upper-lip this is a thing that is in
some of the other supporting cast as
well and I like it it's the same
mentality that you know is why the
musicians kept playing as the Titanic
went down and I always find it to be a
really interesting character trait and I
enjoy it in Jenna
so this was this was a good supporting
cast as well the alien aspect and again
I don't consider that to be a spoiler
either because it's Doctor Who you know
he lands before a historical disaster
you think Oh what's what's going on with
this disaster oh right it's aliens just
somehow becoming my thing after my
Doctor Who episodes in ten words things
anyways the the way the aliens work and
what's going on with them is interesting
and and I'll talk a little bit more
about the specifics of that in terms of
suppose there's actually a couple
different things going on there's
something I'll mention but this happens
really early on there's there's
something called the Vorta sores which
are sort of time vortex predators
they're kind of pterodactyl like and
there's they're sort of fun a little bit
a little bit of a campy monster element
that that factors in and a couple points
but I I have to wonder if the concept of
them informed some of what went into the
Reapers in father's day and that that
series one Christopher Eccleston story
just I don't I mean functionally they're
not doing the same thing but this whole
sort of predator that exists in the
spaces between time and dimensions thing
it's like I feel like this has to be
borrowing that has to be roaring from
this at least slightly maybe not I don't
know
so that I haven't talked too much yet
about the doctor himself about Paul
McGann because in some ways he's a
little bit of the weak link on that I
feel really bad saying that but I find
being honest the thing is is that I
think I went into this having overhyped
it in my head going this is the first
8th doctor audio let's go and not
accounting for the fact that this was
the first one for him and it was his
first time playing this character in a
long time yeah I think it might have
been his first time working in an audio
media bat I'm less certain about you can
tell it's a first outing
and honestly the worst of it is at the
very beginning of the whole thing which
is not a good place to stumble but it
opens he doesn't he's not traveling with
a companion so he's talking to himself
and it's some some of the most painful I
need to describe what it is I'm seeing
so that the listeners understand what's
going on because this is an audio format
writing that I've heard in a while and
it's made all the worse because he is
talking to himself so not only is he
over describing means he's over
describing them for the benefit of just
the listener you know there isn't even
the justification that he's exposing to
to a companion and the I'm not gonna lie
the opening chunk of this the opening of
I don't know five minutes or so is
really clunky and really awkward and
Paul McGann he's not bad he's not off
his game but I feel like he is in I feel
like I'm listening to him in the middle
of the process of slipping back into
this character and he's not quite there
yet he's not bad he's he's good but then
but I gettin the whole thing it it
really definitely does feel like this
was the first go this was the pilot
episode this does have that feel to it
so it makes it a bit more rough around
the edges and it makes something that if
I'm honest I'm unlikely to revisit
mainly because of that that that is my
only criticism about it the only thing
that I think doesn't particularly work
and I know that sounds like a major
things like well the doctor doesn't work
in doctor but he does work again I think
this is partly an issue of me keeping
too many expectations on this thing in
the first place but it is good and I do
recommend checking it out if you haven't
already I am gonna get a little bit into
spoilers so I can talk about some of the
other alien stuff that goes on so coming
down in three two one
why did I count down like that that was
really awkward for my hand so the trace
Kelly that's there's some interesting
things going on with them the whole idea
that they
were sort of this one being with for
lack of a better comparison the sort of
jumble of contradictions and emotions
that we as humans have but they split it
out in two parts to try and distill
things and to bring a better sense of
order and they kind of they basically
create the in the ego and the super-ego
and so you've got the lawgiver being the
logical decision maker of everything
you've got the engineer with all the
creativity and and sort of you know then
that kind of energy and then you've got
the uncreate er you know who just wants
to destroy it as a ball of rage and what
I like about that is that well first of
all it reminds me a little bit of the
Dark Crystal and in terms of I guess
spoiler for the Dark Crystal but you
have you find out at the end that the
Skeksis these evil you know vicious
creatures and the the peaceful mystics
were are actually two halves of one
species that were that were split apart
and so I even reminded me of that which
is nice but I like the doctor sort of
acknowledges huh that was that was an
odd approach but it kind of worked which
I liked and it feels very alien it feels
like that's an alien solution to a weird
problem and I do and I like that for
however long is that the lawgivers been
around that it did work until he's he's
getting ready to die and now we've got a
problem and we have sort of your your
troublemakers cuz you've got the
uncreated Prime on the Triskelion and
then with humans you have Rathbone so
you've got people on both sides making
the situation that honestly isn't even
that bad and is relatively peaceful but
throwing it into disarray because of
what they want or ways in which they are
miscalculating or misjudging the
situation so I mean the main thing I
wanted to say about that is I just I
love the idea of the this
I almost says split personality but that
people didn't usually use that phrase to
mean something else but the sort of
splitting of characteristics and
the the breaking a part of this species
into component parts that had them each
having independent thought was a nicely
alien concept and I also think it works
pretty well in the audio medium because
you just have to shift to the nature of
the Deline delivery to very clearly
distinguish between the three different
parts of the Triskelion so yeah I think
that's it I did enjoy storm warning but
like I said I do think in my head I
overhyped how good it was gonna be to
hear a poem again in audio form and you
know it it's the first go and I expect
that I'll probably I'm well not just
expect I know he does better I've
listened to some of his later audio
stuff so I I know that this is not like
as good as he was ever gonna be
so that's that'll do it storm warning
have you heard it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about if there's all the stuff to
do like support me on patreon like and
subscribe and follow me on Twitter send
me an email and so much more links for
all that stuff
and other stuff as well is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]